hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood
i survived a night unscathed
but there's a friend here if i were you
i wouldn't venture too far from here
unless you got bored of your lousy life
meet only a few returned from the dense
woods and those who made it back were
not able to
share their happy stories okay do you
have anything that i could trade
the the problem is i don't exactly know
what i need
at some point maybe if i survived long
enough i
probably would be able to build a gun
but at this point i think i just need to
explore
gather and just like scavenge
yeah we don't need the torch at the
moment
uh we built the well
oh apparently that's still good for me
to drink
i doubt that very much all right are
these mushrooms that i can gather
no all right there's some kind of a
trail here that i can probably
follow i can definitely use these bear
traps in my uh
oh never mind scrap metal i just
rendered it into pieces with my own bare
hands
no man it's really inconvenient that i
can only see where i'm looking
what happened to me having an omnipotent
view
i actually have to use my eyeballs these
tree trunks yeah they must be
all right so i'm just gonna keep
exploring and i'm not 100 gonna know
exactly where i'm going
but as long as i keep gathering stuff
bringing it back it's
a net positive i just got to make sure
that i
get at least one more thing of gas
because it seems like gas is the big
kahuna
logs are okay but nails and stone i'm
i'm only gonna bring back so many logs
cause i doubt that i could carry that
many
or i doubt i could cut oh
hey you're just in my house
great nice camp though uh i'm just gonna
keep exploring all right
do you mind if i disarm this for scrap
metal good i'm glad you don't have any
opinion about this
i can only assume that i will know when
i approach
something that will kill me this really
looks like something that might kill me
what is it
what is it what is this what am i
looking at what is it where's it glowing
what is that
don't tell me that's nothing that can't
be nothing that's definitely something
hey it's a bonnie okay that's fine oh
this has got to be the dense death woods
are these the death woods
these seem like the yeah i'm i'm not
going to go that way that seems like
death
well good oh my
what am i looking at are you
okay hello
[Music]
you all right there okay i don't know
what's going on with them
hello i don't trust that
[Music]
i don't like that i don't trust that
okay i don't like that i don't trust
that
don't like it don't trust it so i seem
to be reaching the edge of the woods
that i could possibly traverse up here
i'm guessing i gotta take a turn and go
south
maybe i could bring back these logs you
know what let me just do that
i'm not 100 sure what i do with logs
besides just
cut them up i'm guessing that's a good
thing though
cut up the logs into planks get the
nails so you can board up your windows
all for the good right right
no one's answering this why am i asking
why am i shouting into the woods
the things of which i am thinking it's
not like anybody could hear me
all right let's saw some logs saw them
logs
i'm officially out of fuel in that thing
all right
but i can put these here okay good i
guess
um do i have any other storage thing
what is this what is this
uh i have a wardrobe inside i guess are
you still in here man
okay good it would have been weird if
you were bullet
did i put that bullet in there i think i
did
i definitely think i did let's go ahead
and put the nails in there i guess
i got a lot of nails okay whatever it's
fine let's get going
burn in daylight
ah that's a good sound
so i'm starting to realize that these f
these fields oh no they're big
i thought they i thought i was boxed in
but apparently i am not
what is happening here oh found location
wedding wedding
are you sure about that are you sure
that someone would be having a
wedding right about now
can i get gas from this thing
can i get gas from this thing this looks
like something
that uses gas if i had to guess
okay i heard a dog bark but i'm assuming
you're a friendly boochie
all right okay all right poochie good
guard dog you know good
good job well i i might be able to get
around him
[Applause]
okay so if i oh no
oh no i'm stuck okay man whatever
plant this is is tough i can't possibly
walk through it
maybe there's a back way in yeah
yeah yeah
oh yeah so if the dog is still on the
other side i should be able to sprint
around
i'm in i'm in i'm in i'm in hey hi
is anyone here am i alone
oh no i hate it why did i want to come
in here
why would i have wanted to come in oh
why did i want to come in here
oh no who's watching the poochie
oh no
who's who's taking care of the boochie
okay i don't even know if there's a way
through here
probably not i don't like these holes
what are the holes all about i should
have gotten another torch this one's
almost going to run out
oh no hello
oh i don't know that go why would i know
the code
who's thumping
who's something oh an old wagon
decorated with colorful ribbons and
flowers made of white tissue paper that
you know that's fantastic that is really
something
but uh i got a dog problem yipes
all right there was no point in coming
here i got absolutely nothing out of
that experience that oral ordeal was
really really not wise for me to come
down here
but hey i found the wedding
beautiful wedding all right what is that
crate locked i could open with a lock
pick do i have one of those i
do lockpick unlocked all right
ho ho
okay so i got gas that's good because
that's the thing that's gonna get me
through the night if i don't have gas
i'm out on my ass
that sounds big
what could possibly sound that big
oh that
oh clearly that's normal okay i'm back
to the creek
and the impassable oh you got a whole
bunch of friends here
oh wait there's a way in oh where does
this go
oh do i want to go this way i don't
think i do
but here i go oh
someone's house here
oh my god the woods really just kind of
closed up this whole place
we're gonna drag this see if we can get
by
there we go
[Applause]
okay yeah this is gonna go well for me
that definitely wasn't keeping something
out
oh my oh my god
what was the point of that why did you
make me see the nightmare of the oozing
undulating bodies was there something
that i was supposed to do was
no please not like this anything but
then
help dog help i mean not help
not dog help okay yeah i know i need to
get through this
all right cool good have fun there
you'll probably be safe there dog
it's fine what is this oh how did i miss
this house oh hey hey nothing
nothing nothing nothing nothing there is
no need
there's no need got some sploring to do
here
hello nobody better be in here
that's all i got to say about that
odd looking mushroom cookable rots over
time oh i can put things i forgot i can
put things um
here that's probably for the best and
then flare would be good
why'd that sound like that was in here
no from the burned house i know they're
there
i can hear them laughing they're behind
the wall of trees i can't get through by
myself the trees grow back too fast
yeah something about this universe where
the freaking trees
just started growing exponentially and
then they never stopped and they took
over everything
like something started mutating like the
trees
oh good thing i jacked white dress a
white
child's dress that's not a good thing
i'll come back for that this fabric says
it has high value
that might be like a quest item or
something hey
ah hi uh listen there's no need there's
no need there's no need
hey there's no need ah
my walls why would you do that to me
please don't kill me please i am out of
running i'm out of run
i'm out of run i'm out thank you
is that your house i apologize i
took your fine cloth very nice
but it's mine now so go away this is my
house
all right good good good good the well
is dry at the moment i should check
back tomorrow you know sure
and half for the generator i'm guessing
there's no harm in making sure that the
majority of the stuff actually goes in
the generator
oh it was empty oh god it was empty
oh no i should have filled this first oh
i hope i have enough for a night oh i
left it on when i left the house didn't
i
oh no i'm dumb i'm gonna
die oh i'm dumb i left it on when i left
the house
oh i'm dumb okay whatever at least i
have
planks that's what really matters it's
almost night i am
going to die okay i gotta reinforce uh
that that window's good
um i need to get my nails and put my
stuff away and get my nails get my
boards
put this away uh that needs to be cooked
the scrap metal needs to go away uh the
battery the fine cloth
okay then i need to cook the stuff
before this thing
dies okay put it in put it in put it in
that's a dose oh
i'm gonna go with the i can see farther
that
really honestly i need to choose a
negative perk
oh staying in dark areas at night can be
dangerous you know that's fine i wasn't
gonna stay in dark areas anyway
i really wasn't gonna do that i don't
know if the game
thought i was but i really wasn't gonna
i need to turn the generator on oh my
god it's almost night
oh my god okay i'm gonna turn the
generator on and everything's gonna be
fine
oh god that's a body was there always a
body in there
there might have been a body in there
okay okay okay okay i need to barricade
uh this you need three
and so yeah okay
i barricade this window okay
the door is barricaded the only real
problem is that there's
you know this here that's just open
oh god i just moved it it's all good
it's all good okay i wish my work bench
wasn't all the way over there because
if i could maybe i can move it
oh i can dodge i didn't know that
ah bored with nails that sounds cool is
that a weapon
sounds like a weapon a crude weapon but
it's a weapon okay that's good
i've got that okay
upgrade workshop oh i love that yeah
i love that oh yeah upgrade item
i can't okay that's fine i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go i've got a weapon
i feel better and now that i have a
weapon okay
i did good today was a successful day i
really went out there i gave him my all
and i got all that i needed
what is my objective again i forget i
need to go to a door mark 21
something like that
excuse me that that sounded like
quits footsteps in my house
no
i'm not gonna answer the door
the whispering is not appreciated
something is lurking in the shadows i
should stick to yeah you're whoa
oh no
oh no oh i will lump
anything there come on debbie
oh no
be ready for a wampage what do i do
oh there's a light on in there i gotta
go to the other light
oh god it's turned on how'd you get it
i'll kill you i'll kill you ow
you try try me dodge and wamp
and dodge and
ow you hurt really badly i'm gonna lead
you to my one
ow my one defense the bear trap will get
you
ha ha you've been got you
have been got i almost died
that's okay i have bandages how did he
got in from
clearly i know how he got in he got in
through the giant hole
in my house of which i can do nothing
about
because it's just a hole at least my
whomping ability is okay
did i survive at night
very dramatic
ah
day three good gained reputation trader
hey who why are you in my house who is
there
who's there hi how are you
hey oh
a man roughly my size of standing before
me i can barely make out his
disturbingly familiar features through
the matte
visor of his mask the massive helmet is
covered with an old sack and seems to be
an integral part of the unnatural
pale body i remember him he's the one
who rescued me from the doctor's house
the man reaches out to me with his black
hand it's covered in charcoal
there's something written on his worn
woolen glove we need to stick together
brother
his lips are moving but all sounds are
drowned inside the helmet
he shrugs then takes the huge sack off
his back and drops it on the ground
revealing its contents show item photo
of road
he wipes his left glove on his pants
takes out the charcoal from his pocket
and starts scribbling when he finishes
he lifts his dirty hands
all roads lead deeper into the woods
good point trade oh my goodness
do you want some fabric i have fabric
you would love fabric i'm sure that
fabric is probably useful for me
but hang on a second i'll be right back
i'll be right back you stay you don't
move a muscle
all right this scrap metal uh
you want rock throwable
okay okay all right hey hey bud
okay you pat's me on the shoulder we're
friends
we're friends okay cool
all right sell sure sell
five let's do five um let's sell the
fabric
very nice fabric very nice uh you can
have this bullet because
i don't know when the heck i'm ever
gonna have a gun
so i might as well get the money first
and then worry about that
later in in return i would like
an axe blade would be cool but i don't
know if you have a handle
i mean the gasoline honestly
right now that's the only thing that i
know has
value is the gasoline so i'll take the
gasoline
other than that i suppose i could take
the boards
boards and nails i really those are
again
i don't know what has value in this
universe but i know
these have immediate usage that's what i
know
tape tape is probably it's very valuable
though so i'm i'm not gonna go for that
all right let's do this thank you
thank you friend thanks buddy we gotta
stick together pal
all right do i have in my inventory yes
i do
okay oh turn off the generator
god i'm so stupid i left it on blazing
away i'm
so dumb switch off it was almost dead
anyway okay let's fill her up
with this and then probably the other
one too
i'm guessing it uses one section those
bars are like
per day it uses each each one of those
is one all right
i'm going to not fill it up all the way
fill it up to two slots okay now there's
two slots there
that's good i wish i could do something
about this giant
gaping hole in my house
but sadly looks like no a chain trap
bear trap hmm good but i need a torch
so i'll use up this one then use that
one
upgrade item i don't know what i upgrade
more more more nails
maybe more nails all right um i don't
know if that's a good idea
i don't know this weapon nails
i don't know what i should hold on to
what i shouldn't so i'm just gonna keep
it where it is all right let's put these
away in that away
good enough i'll put the rest of the gas
in my wood chopper
oh crap well you know there's no point
there's a giant hole in my house anyway
so why would i go there
at night i should stand there and hold
that in place
gloog okay that's good 97 that's good
drink us good
all right that'll do i'll keep these
boards on me just in case i find
something that needs
them all right let's venture out let's
not waste this beautiful day
this glorious day i'm gonna go southwest
i think that's an area that i haven't
explored really
there's got to be some goodies oh that
whole field is
boned now don't feel these mega bone
high corpse you are a corpse right
better be of corpse thank you cool
thank you corpse oh that ain't good
all right well it's their fault for
camping it's not really the place for
recreational activities
jose you want to repeat the noise again
so i can discern what it was
no all right fine then be rude see if i
care
more crops who's
farming
big moose a deer a buck
a big buck run away oh no no no no you
were supposed to run away you were
supposed to be afraid of me
oh no please please please i don't want
it
no that probably would have insta killed
me i thought he would have been afraid
of me but apparently
no i'm not very intimidating how many
dogs are out here
oh my goodness i don't think there's
anything more over there
okay yeah i'm starting to feel less bad
about the
poochies by the second uh did i get this
i searched this yeah okay so really
there's not much
else out here like it seems like there's
a oh
oh oh my goodness i was
bare i barely went anyway i didn't even
know i had a map
i hit m just to see great
uh can i make a lock pick need to wha
guy i left my wire back
uh i forgot about that hey pooch don't
mind me
bear trap i love it okay
i'll use this bear trap on you and i
won't feel bad about it hey pooch
pooch
hit the bear trap you didn't hit the
bear trap
okay you want you want to dance you want
dance you want dance
okay i will dance with you oh no
no no no no
no i feel bad now ah
what have i done what have i done
i didn't need to do that the dog was
gonna be fine
broken tractor oh good new wire battery
scrap oh why did i do that
okay i don't feel bad anymore i don't
feel bad i feel bad about nothing the
nature is hell here
nature is hell as a hell
hell am i seeing farther by the way is
this farther i
actually have no comparison to make so
i'm assuming that my eyes are better
and that the dark is scarier and it's
only scarier because i can see
farther and i know it's scary that's how
i know
i gotta get back i gotta drop off i i
need more containers
i just need more containers because i
have all this stuff
no poochy i don't wanna have to kill
again okay so there's apparently a way
forward north
of my house which is fascinating
didn't know that existed thank goodness
no one has the ambition to come by and
steal my gas
i'll be really peeved about that
okay then i'll be able to chop more logs
which i'm assuming is what i should be
doing with all this gas i just pouring
that on the ground
i was oh my god i just poured that all
over the ground
oh i'm an idiot i mean good trap i guess
but
man that would really snot smart of me i
wish i could open that container i have
no idea how
dude ah he's not here okay whatever it's
fine
i am out of space what do i do with all
the crap that i have
how do i make what can i make wire do i
have to get wire how do i make wire
i don't know how to get wire single shot
pistol
okay whoo
whoo who the hell
can i can i rearm no it's a scrap now
okay i've got another wardrobe here i'll
it's gonna have to do
and then the scrap metal
i'm gonna preemptively because i know
i'm gonna need it later i'm gonna drag
this thing over
by this so that i can have light over
here i don't know how it's getting power
anyway
that make a whole lot of sense but
whatever it's fine
all right let's go um let's go to the
north let's see where this weird path
leads
i don't know how much light i
is that a storm oh
great it's raining
[Applause]
i found a burned house up here i don't i
see a
car ah okay
i found the burned house great
oh there's a tractor good more gas
hopefully
got it rag flare
okay good locked i need a key
okay out says who
hello the truck is here
no what
get the f out here
okay you talking to me
oh this destroyed generator don't look
too happy all right
uh i guess i can't get through here
it's all walled off all right cool y'all
have fun now
i don't like the rain i mean i like the
rain in general but i don't like the
rain right now feels bad
feels like something terrible is gonna
happen i guess
i'll uh no i'll make a lantern
ah why did i barricade that door
need to upgrade my workshop oh come on
well then why is it listed i
upgraded it already oh oh it's grayed
out oh i see okay
well gosh darn it you gave me hope for
nothing hot bar upgrade
the fabric ah the fabric i didn't oh i
sold my
inventory upgrade on the fabric i sold
the
oh i didn't know that the fabric was
gonna be good for that
i'm sure that fabric is probably useful
for me
great okay i guess i'll just put the
mushroom in the thing and then
fill the generator up the rest of the
way it's the best i got and the best i
can do
i don't even know what it is that i'm
shooting into my veins no
stop yeah i really i don't even know
what it is is it good to inject that
into me
all right that's full up that's good
i don't know how soon tonight it's
impossible to know with the freaking
sky crying on me is there a way to drop
stuff can i just drop things
would if i um i'm gonna guess no
yes okay
it does well that's good i wonder if it
would be better to move a light in here
and then
close up the door and barricade this
area that might be a little safer
well i guess in the same principle i
could just barricade that door
all right then i guess i gotta make up
my mind soon it's probably almost night
or maybe it is i i have no idea is it
night
how would i know uh i might have time to
go down
i have no idea i have no idea what time
it is
you know i'm gonna guess no i'm gonna
guess i i mean
maybe no there's got to be time
there has to be time
oh oh yeah there's a pass through here
oh what were those what was that what
was that
what did i just see kind of bug ass bugs
oh
big ticks big ticks get out of here
get out of here oh i hate that oh i hate
the hole
oh the hole i hate it oh my god
oh my god is it night oh my god is it
night right now
oh no infected with something toxic i
need to find a way to get rid of it
yeah you know good point hey good bread
love bread
oh my god oh my god need a key
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh god what time is it i have
no idea
what time is it i don't know ah i can't
touch that that's poisonous
oh you know what i'm out of here this
was terrible idea i shouldn't have come
here i'm gonna look in a crate and then
i'm gonna it's night now
oh my god no oh no
no oh no oh it's it's not night i
thought it was night it's just dark
okay it's but it's almost night but
night almost is the thing that is now
okay where's my house here uh
i don't know where i am on this map
there's my house my house
yes house yes turn it on open it
close it get in the hole okay i'm gonna
cover this in cover it cover it cover it
cover it correct
cover it and no one will ever know um
i could drag in here and maybe that's
the best idea that might be the best
idea
i'm going for this area in here um i'll
barricade this i might just
stay here or maybe i can craft something
okay center of the room
perfect close this up barricade it
my wood nails wood nails wood nails wood
nails
wood nails okay and i'm safe
i think i could i could upgrade my
more more nail you know more nails you
know
more nails okay it is night now i am
locked in
no one can get me and in case they can
i've got my super whomper nailed i just
look
so many nails i've wailed into this
plank
anyone that comes to try to get me will
die
a horrible death i really shouldn't have
sold the fabric i didn't know
i didn't know i didn't know how would i
know how would i have known
okay
who wants to go home you're in my home
go to your own home
squeaky board that's a squeaky board
that's a very squeaky board
okay looks like uh looks like i'm making
it through the night
ah day four good
great made it to day four hey
is that the traitor do i get anything
back from that
i don't do i damn it so you just use up
everything
okay hey bud hey you know
you know you know that you know that
fabric i gave you
ah damn it you really want to charge a
lot for that okay
oh you want some bread good bread for
you all right you know what you're
you're real cool you're real cool dude
you're real cool dude and you're my
friend
i'd like your wire please the watch
a watch so i know what time it is
that would be so intelligent that would
be
really handy
oh yes oh yes
yes yes yes give give
he nods good we're good friends you and
i
and now i have a watch eight o'clock 8
a.m okay that's good
you know what that's good this is cool
this game is just really cool it's
terrifying
i don't know why but it's terrifying
everything about it is terrifying but
i'm making progress
i made a few mistakes but nothing i
can't learn from so thank you everybody
so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you